I never thought of you as having a
raunchy sense of humor but clearly I was
wrong you come out here oh I'm so
disappointed in my own sense of humor I
don't like I got to 15 years old and
then my brain just froze like I heard a
joke when I was 15 and my brain never
grew past it you never got past that
sense of you know no no and the joke was
it's really dumb joke but it's just guys
walking down the beach he finds a genie
bottle the genie comes out and says I'll
give you one wish the guy goes I want to
take that'll touch the ground so the
genie cut the guy's legs off and I never
got past that joke every ball you also
said it so quickly you said it like an
auctioneer you stopped right there yeah
I did I just did yeah I don't know man I
really wish I could to clean comedy
sometimes people come in if they see
like the wall or talking dead or
whatever and then I'm and then I tell a
joke about jerking off in traffic
they're a little you know first turned
on and then upset yes
what's also your look you'll have a very
clean cut I do ish look yeah and you
have a very nice manner come out and I
think that that's where it Mike you
could probably get some people I don't
know why an old pirate is enjoying your
comedy party to do a parrot why don't I
go over there I could have got well why
don't I do this okay whatever anyway I'm
totally screwing up but yes that was
that that could surprise people so sorry
so I do apologize in advance for I
apologize post for all the filthy jokes
approach you don't apologize for real
you love it I do make chopped off his
legs and that's how his dick
this is what I feel like we could have a
team act all right tell a joke really
fast and I had you break it down yeah
yeah so in that joke
the guy was wanting him to make the dick
who wants to be a millionaire doing that
voice anymore so why don't we use it
the genie cut the guy's legs off I don't
get it Regis is out now doing the
filthiest act there is in Vegas okay no
I made that up that's not true 100 years
old I tripped over my own balls I gotta
roll them up with a sardine can key what
am i doing over here
all right you went too far
you